good evening as you no doubt noticed
already c-span is with us tonight so
please be careful as you're walking
around of equipment and cables and the
camera crew has asked that when you have
it when it comes time to ask questions
that you go to the mic there so that the
viewing audience has an opportunity here
your question as well for monitors of
all stripes have taken a certain pride
over the past six and a half years from
Washington news articles that read like
this quote the measure was supported by
a coalition of legislators a total of
148 Democrats and 60 Republicans and
representative Bernie Sanders
independent of Vermont back to the
amendment the Democrats get lumped the
Republicans get lumped and congressman
Sanders Bernie stands out in the
Washington crowd in more ways than one
may I call you Bernie that seems more
appropriate than congressman Sanders in
this intimate state Bernie Sanders is
the only independent in the United
States House of Representatives no other
independent has been elected in over to
congressman over 40 years and none has
been ever served for talk terms which
bernie is currently doing Vermonters
elected him to his fourth term by a wide
margin of 23 percentage points Bernie
Sanders is a Democratic Socialist which
makes my wife and me and the entire
northshire crew who are all interested
in fostering wide and diverse exchanges
of views very grateful to for him to
agreeing to come to our Valley which is
known as a Republican stronghold on
NPR's Morning Edition this spring Bernie
was asked to explain the difference
between the socialist and the Democrat a
liberal Democrat and the ensuing
discussion was intriguing at times it
resembled a civics lesson our
congressman does an exceptional job of
working his way into the wolf and warp
of the Washington policymaking fabric
despite his independent status he chairs
the 58 member house Progressive Caucus a
group that helped spearhead the
full opposition to Newt Gingrich he also
made legislative history when he became
the ranking minority member of the
Subcommittee on economic growth and
natural resources of the Government
Reform Committee and in Bernie's
political autobiography whose
publication we are celebrating tonight
you'll read how his Brooklyn childhood
shaped his political beliefs and you'll
follow his improbable 25-year trek from
fringe party candidate to major mayor of
Burlington and on to his present
congressional prominence the book will
give you behind the scenes views of his
re-election campaign in the battle with
Susan sweet Syria as well as sometimes
humorous sometimes moving passages about
what the state has meant to him over the
years and two accounts of his
legislative battles with the Gingrich
but most of all you got a clear
understanding of his message and his
analysis of the class struggle the
United States today Bernie wrote this
fine book with his longtime friend Huck
gutmann who was sitting here a
University of Vermont English professor
he has offered three other books and
taught as a Fulbright Fulbright senior
lecturer in the new university of lisbon
and portugal and has lectured widely on
both politics and literature in india
tunisia lithuania and Egypt the issues
Bernie Sanders champions are legion I
started to make a list of the more
prominent ones a more significant ones
but that got too long besides it's
better to hear them from him suffice it
to say that Vermonters reelected him
because of his unique voice he stands up
to speak for working-class people and
low-income people and the elderly people
and a vast body of citizens who don't
vote because they don't feel part of the
two-party system we feel privileged to
have him spend the evening with us at
the northshire bookstore Ernie thank you
for coming
thank you very much ed for that very
generous introduction and let me thank
not share our books for having this
reading here tonight as I think all of
you know and one of the points that how
can I make in our books in our book is
that in industry after industry there is
growing concentration of ownership and
certainly one of the areas that that is
taking place is in bookselling and fine
independent bookstores like North Shore
being asked to compete against very
large multinational chains and we're
very proud that in the state of Vermont
we have such fine book stores as North
Shore and we're also delighted that
c-span's here tonight because similarly
in terms of the media it is it will talk
about this later increasingly difficult
to get alternative points of view out
through a media which is again owned and
controlled by a few very very large
corporations and c-span I think is one
of the bright lights and contemporary
television at least than that
alternative points of view can get out
around the country ah let me tell you a
little bit as to why Huck and I wrote
the book outsider in the house he and I
have been progressives for all of our
adult life and we detect that all over
this country there is a feeling of
pessimism and depression among
progressives not only because of the
rise of the right wing in this country
or Newt Gingrich but also because of in
many respects the collapse of the
Democratic Party and the understanding
that with all of the problems facing
this country we have a two-party system
which is heavily dominated by big money
interests and that most of the very
important issues facing ordinary people
are not only not dealt with effectively
they are very rarely even discussed so a
tuck and I wanted to do in this book is
to show the people of this country that
it is possible to function politically
outside of the two-party system that you
can take on the Democratic Party you can
take on the Republican Party you can
take on big
money interest and if you are persistent
enough or in my case may be dumb enough
that you keep coming back year after
year you can actually have some success
and I think that that's a lesson that
needs to get out all across this country
because of the many problems that we
write in the book write about in the
book probably the one that we feel most
strongly about is the fragility of
American democracy the fact that in the
last presidential election we had less
than half of the people vote in what was
in fact the very important election that
two years before that when Gingrich and
his friends took power we had thirty
eight percent of the american people
voting sixty-two percent did not think
it was important enough to vote that
poor people in america virtually have no
participation in the political process
most working people do not and that we
felt that it is important to talk about
that problem and to give some hope to
people when many respects have lost hope
in the political process and i think the
message that we wanted to make is that
if you have the guts and the persistence
to stand up to identify yourselves with
working families and low-income people
if you take a message out to the
american people that if good people come
together regardless of their background
if we're talking about people in the
trade union movement or workers people
who are active in women's rights or
environmental rights or veterans rights
or concerns about senior citizens or
concerns about children that a people
are able to put aside their little
differences and come together and ask
the questions about why this great
country is not providing a decent
standard of living for all of its people
that if you can reach out to those
people you can be successful so i would
say that most importantly what this book
is about is in fact a measure of hope at
a time when for many progressives all
over this country things are not looking
good and we want to say that if you talk
about the right issues and we talk about
our view of what we think those issues
are
if you reach out to people if you bring
people together and if you're persistent
and you keep coming back and back and
back you can win so that's probably the
most important point that we wanted to
make and second of all we wanted to talk
to people especially I think young
people about the importance of politics
a lot of young people have not a clue
about the relevance of politics to their
lives and I have regarded as one of the
important aspects of my job as Vermont's
only congressman to go out to almost
every one of our high schools over the
last five or six years and talk to the
kids because I think it is important
that young people understand that
politics no matter what their point of
view maybe is extremely important to
their lives and many of them do not
understand that and we used as a perhaps
a case history the work that we did when
I was mayor of Burlington from 1981 to
1989 and we showed how progressives were
prepared to stand up and fight for the
right things can make a profound change
in a community and in the process of
doing that can revitalize democracy in
the City of Burlington one of the
accomplishments that I am most proud of
is that over a four-year period and as
you all know we have elections in
Vermont every two years there were four
year period from nineteen seventy nine
to nineteen eighty-three we came close
to doubling the voter turnout in the
City of Burlington that a lot of working
people and young people who had
otherwise given up on the political
process came out to vote and not only to
vote but to participate in the political
process because they realize that
politics could be relevant to their
lives as we started various types of
councils which had power as we extended
political power to low income and
working people into women the people
concerned about the environment as we
made concrete changes in the city people
said you know what I guess government
does make a difference look what we can
accomplish if we work together so we
very proudly talk about what we
accomplished in Burlington not just you
know because we're proud of that and we
are but to show that if you're prepared
to
reach out to people and develop a
grassroots democracy you know what
people will come in and participate the
reason that half the American people
don't vote and probably in the next
congressional election you'll have 65
seventy percent of the people not coming
out to vote is not in my view the fault
of the people it's the people look out
on the political landscape people watch
the television and they do not see or
understand the relevance of politics to
their lives some people do know the
relevance of politics to their lives and
those are the people who contribute 50
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars to the political parties of
their choice they go to the five
thousand all the fundraising dinners the
Republicans and Democrats give they
understand the relevance of politics but
then the word goes out to ordinary
people to the working stiffs of this
country hey don't get involved everybody
is a crook you don't want to really you
don't need to understand all about these
things trade policy it's too esoteric
for your foreign policy forget it the
environment forget it you don't need to
know about those stuff will give you a
Jay Simpson on the television you don't
have to participate in this stuff will
give you you know sex and sensationalism
but politics is too hard for you just
leave it to the experts leave it to the
lobbyists inside the beltway so we talk
about Burlington is a case history of
what happens when you open up city
government and you bring people in and
you helped to transform what goes on
there and then we also do something in
the book which i think is interesting
and that is a lot of progressives all
over this country are intimidated by the
political process well gee I mean how do
you go about doing it I mean how do you
raise money how do you reach out to the
media how do you do all of these things
so what we do in the book is perhaps
give people a behind the scenes I
approach an understanding of what goes
on in a in a real tough campaign as ed
mentioned we ended up winning this
campaign by a very generous vote but
when we began the campaign let me tell
you that is not what we understood what
would happen it's always nice to know
the ending if you know the ending before
you begin life becomes a lot easier our
but in in this campaign we were taking
on uh not only Gingrich and the
leadership of the Republican Party
am proud to tell you is Vermonters that
I was on the hit list the top dozen for
gingrich in the national republican
committee and as some of you may have
remembered we had every leading
republican from the chairman of the
national republican committee uh to dick
on me who is the majority leader every
week they were bringing in somebody else
i was on a hitless and i gave the legal
maximum amount of money that they
possibly could to my opponent and in
addition to that we made another hit
list I made to hit list and that is
corporate America's hit list and I was
also singled out the is one of those
folks they wanted to get rid of so we're
taking on both of those very very
powerful groups and we wanted to show
people around the country again that
despite taking on the most powerful
political organization probably in the
world that's the National Republican
Committee on time and taking on big
money interest you can do it and we give
a little bit behind the scenes
discussion of what it is like to run a
progressive campaign how do you do it
folks here in Manchester receive
literature door-to-door distributed by
our campaign well how do we do that you
got some telephone calls maybe you
didn't want to get them but you got them
from Sanders for Congress well how do
you organize a grassroots telephone a
campaign how when your supporters don't
have the kinds of money that your
opponent has the book begins actually
with my getting very nervous when dick
ami came to the state of Vermont for a
five-hundred-dollar replayed breakfast
for my opponent well needs of the say
Bernie Sanders doesn't have five hundred
dollar a plate functions if I did my
supporters would laugh me out of the
room very few of them have five hundred
dollars to contribute to a campaign so
how do you deal with that how do you
raise money we ended up raising a
million dollars how do you do that well
you do it by getting over 20,000 people
to contribute on average thirty-five
dollars a piece and we talk about the
five dollar bills that come in from
senior citizens all over the country
occasionally a rumpled one dollar bill
and the notes that go with that so if
you can't raise money from corporate
packs and I don't take any money from
corporate packs and you don't get a lot
of money from rich folks how do you
raise the money that you need to mount
the serious campaign and we talk about
that
how do you reach out to the media how do
you do political advertising should a
progressive a Democratic Socialist do
30-second television ads or is that
somehow immoral and we should just let
the Republicans and the Democrats do it
well we do and we do well occasionally
we've done five minutes how do you do
that and we talked about that so we
wanted to tell people all over the
country who are interested in electoral
politics give them some hands-on
information about how they could mount a
campaign and then we also wanted to talk
about the role that I've been playing in
Congress now many of you know you know
you hear about this issue in that issue
but I wanted to put it together and I
also wanted to put it in the context of
the Gingrich agenda as you know when
Gingrich and his friends were elected
they launched what many people consider
to the most to be the most extreme
right-wing agenda in the certainly the
modern history the United States of
America and as chairman of the 58 member
Progressive Caucus I helped along with
the number of other members of Congress
play a strong role in I wouldn't say
defeating that agenda but at least
slowing it down significantly so they
were it not able to go as far as they
wanted to go and I talked about other
issues when i was first elected to
congress way back in nineteen ninety one
i dealt with issues like the Persian
Gulf and I incursion Gulf War and I
opposed that one and I wanted to tell
you how it felt to be a member of
Congress to put his card in the way you
vote in Congress got a little cod looks
like a credit card you put it in the
machine to press yes-mo and on one of
the votes on the Persian Gulf War there
were I think six other members of
Congress who voted with me and I said my
god it's gonna be a very short political
career you know putting in there looked
up on the bulletin board of there's a
board over there nobody's up there yet
all right well I think this war is wrong
and pressed my but you know press the
button as well okay two years that's it
but it turned out not to be the case we
talked about the role that we play you
know as some of you know despite the
fact that the Republicans control both
the House and the Senate last year we
were able to raise the minimum wage and
that is an issue that I've been working
on from my first day in Congress know
how do you do that how do you raise the
minimum wage when you have the
leadership of the Republican Party who
controls both bodies adamantly opposed
to raising the minimum age where the way
you do it is to create a grassroots
movement
so that the overwhelming majority of the
American people end up saying no it is
more immoral it is absurd to ask people
to live on four dollars and twenty-five
cents an hour and we did that we
developed the grassroots movement to do
that and there is a lesson to be learned
in that that when you involve people in
the political struggle for common-sense
ideas that the vast majority of the
people believe then even people I
Gingrich are going to be forced to bend
and they did and I also talked a little
bit in the book we have a chapter on
what we call the scapegoating Congress
and this is what that is about is he mr.
Gingrich and mr. army have a real
problem and their problem is that they
represent about to three percent of the
people in America richest people in
America and it is very hard for them to
go forward to the American people who
put ads on television saying American
people I want you to vote for me so we
can give huge tax breaks to the rich and
then cut back on Medicare Medicaid and
education please vote for us well they
probably wouldn't get a whole lot of
votes if they did that but that's really
what their program is about they
represent the millionaires and the
billionaires and multinational
corporations now that's their problem
how do they solve their problem they
solve it in a very brilliant way with a
lot of polling and a lot of enormous
sophistication what they do is divide
America up in a dozen different ways
they play black off against light and
white off against Hispanic they play
Native Americans against immigrants they
play men against women straight against
gays and they sit down they do intensive
research on how you can divide the
country up so that you have working
class people and middle-class people
ending up voting against their own best
interest because they've been told that
the reason they are working 50 or 60
hours a week as they are is not because
corporate America is taking their jobs
to China in Mexico uh-uh it's because
all those poor people living high off
the hog in welfare so we all suppose to
hate the welfare people okay and we
don't look at what's happening on the
top and we're supposed to lower taxes
for the rich because presumably they're
going to reinvest in America and create
great jobs here despite the history of
the last 30 years which says that is a
exactly not the case okay so what they
have they do and we talk about how they
do it they do it with homophobia there
was a lead piece of legislation very
clearly designed for the election time
to you know rouse hatred against gay
people and so forth and so on and we
talked a little bit about the
scapegoating Congress and then we end
the book in what I think is an
interesting way maybe I'll just read a
little bit about that and talk about
that and that is what we say is ok you
know we've talked about a lot of things
but it is fair of us to tell the reader
where do we go from here and we talked
about the past this is 1997 I've been
reelected for my fourth term uh where do
we go from here and what are the most
important issues facing this country and
how might we address those issues and
let me just touch on what Huck and I
concluded there are the most important
issues say a few words about that and
then we can open it up for discussion
first issue that we feel like to be
enormously important is that while the
wealthiest people in America are
becoming much richer the fact of the
matter is most people are becoming
poorer or at best hanging and
economically so I know you've been
reading a lot on the front pages of
newspapers about the great economic boom
but as I go around the state of Vermont
people say what must the past over
Vermont not for me I'm working three
jobs somebody's getting a boom but it
ain't me and what the reality is and how
can I go into it a little bit and let me
just touch on that issue well let me
tell you some of the other issues and
I'll go back to so that's the first
issue that despite would you read in the
newspapers you know what do they say
about liars and statistics a lot of
statistics out there about economic
growth and increased income but they
forgot to tell you the real truth that
is that almost all of the increased
wealth is going to the richest 1% the
richest 5% people in the middle class
are working longer hours for lower wages
and so forth we'll talk about that in a
moment and then the another issue that
is of enormous consequence which is
virtually not talked about at all is the
crisis in American democracy today the
fragility of
American democracy I am not quite sure
what you would describe the phenomenon
the political phenomenon that gives us
that America thing now we knew for
example that seven or eight years ago
before Nelson Mandela took power in the
African National Congress took power in
South Africa you had a country there
which had a democracy but it was a
democracy limited to the minority the
white people and black people did not
have the right to vote that was pretty
clear situation is different in America
with few limitations basically anybody
who really wants to can register to vote
sometimes it's hard but you can do it
and yet the reality is that in the next
congressional election in 1988 I'm
guessing that maybe thirty five percent
of the people vote sixty-five percent of
the people will not vote so people now
can vote but they don't feel low income
people probably into the tune of eighty
and ninety percent don't vote at all
very large numbers of young people don't
vote you have elections which are
dominated as you all know by big money
so you have a lot of people not voting
people in most in need absolutely do not
look to the political system as a
solution to their problems and elections
are dominated by the people who have the
money is that a democracy now mr.
Gingrich and his friends get their way
the perfect election will be is when you
have a handful of people with a lot of
money voting that will be the essence of
democracy and the vast majority of
people not fighting we talk about things
like clinton signed the bill a couple
years ago that is a small step forward
in the right direction is called motor
voter making it easier for working
people low-income people to register and
vote incredibly enough you had
republican governors in california
elsewhere around the country fought this
to thin out the idea that poor people
might participate in the political
process what is this world coming to
don't they understand that politics is
only for the rich in the powerful and
they try to really not implement the
motor photo/bill and people i go to
court and so forth and so on and how can
I discuss how can we go further how do
you open up the political process going
back to the City of Burlington we open
up the political process we showed that
if you open the door and you tell people
that you can make a change it can have
an impact on your lives people will walk
in the door but certainly that is not
the agenda certainly of the Republican
Party and
many people in the Democratic Party as
well so we talked about that important
issue and then we talked about another
issue that is never ever talked about on
CBS or NBC or ABC or Fox and I'll tell
you what it is you promise not to tell
anybody the issue is corporate control
over the media see now you may not even
be familiar with that issue because
nobody talks about that issue what's up
you ain't gonna see a program on CBS
about corporate control the meeting
you're not gonna see it on NBC and yet
it is perhaps of all of the issues we
can argue which is more important I
would argue it ranks up there is one of
the very very most important issues and
it's not talked about by anybody so let
me give the people in this room a quiz
here who owns NBC anyone know general
election general electric one of the
largest corporations in America who owns
CBS Westinghouse who owns ABC Mickey
Mouse and Disney and who owns the Fox
television network our friend Rupert
Murdoch the right-wing billionaire okay
so those are the people who control most
of what Americans learn about because as
you know is EDD will probably tell you
here books people are reading less and
less books and people get more and more
than information from television so
you'll have four large right-wing
multinational corporations who are
telling the American people what they
are supposed to know and let me tell you
the results of what they do are
absolutely astounding for example you
find that there was a poll done a couple
years ago Washington Post in Harvard did
a poll and they ask the American people
you know basic knowledge about the
political process and they said can you
tell us the names of your to United
States senators seventy-five percent of
the american people could not name their
to United States senators what can you
tell us the name of your member of
Congress sixty-six percent of the people
could not name their member of Congress
so okay who is the vice president of the
United States of America that's a tough
one and he has a short last name
forty percent could not named Al Gore as
the vice president of the United States
and then they asked people where is your
tax dollars going now if you listen to
Gingrich and his friends the way we
spend all of our money is foreign aid
and welfare right that's about one
percent each okay so people didn't have
a clue about how much we spend on the
fence spending about tax breaks for the
wealthy about taxes and people don't
know it and one of the reasons they know
don't see the stuff no one sees the
stuff on television now for example I
happen to believe and discuss in this
book the importance of working people
coming together in trade unions as a way
to improve their lives on the job
traders of unions earn about twenty-five
percent more than non-union workers and
when unions come together there have
able to have a political impact in
Washington okay so I I'm a pro trade
union person has anybody in this room
and I should tell you they're about 15
million Americans that's a lot of people
who belong to trade unions in America as
anybody in this room ever seen on
prime-time television one program which
talks about the positive role the trade
unions play in America it's not allowed
to be on this basically not allowed to
be on the air you haven't seen 15
million trade unions the unions have
played a very important role not only in
workers rights and in decent wages but
in things like Social Security Medicare
Medicaid affordable housing many other
programs not one work basically kept off
via and we even talked about so-called
public television public television is a
lot of programs for people invest in the
stock market and all these other
business type areas there's no program
on public television about the needs of
working people because you know they
don't put huge amounts of money into
public television so we talked about
that we talked a little bit about health
care and the crisis and health care and
how if Bill Clinton had done the things
in the last three years the corporate
America has done in terms of health care
he would probably been strung up you
know because we talked years and years
ago about the sanctity of the
doctor-patient relationship remember
that but some of you may still have a
doctor whose name you know the sanctity
was very important when people opposed
and I didn't support Clinton's bill I
believe in a single-payer health care
system but now no one worries about the
sanctity of the doctor-patient
relationship is we're all forced into
managed care and into HMOs and we talk
what about education but let me say a
little bit about the economy read your
briefly from the book and say this
because you're not going to see this on
television too often as well the richest
one percent of Americans now own
forty-two percent of the nation's wealth
that's a lot forty-two percent compared
with nineteen percent in 1976 the top 1%
now owns more than the bottom ninety
percent now you ever see that discussion
taking place the morality of that okay
that's a discussion we don't see too
often on television in order we see it
within the Democratic Republican Party's
between 1983 and 1989 sixty-two percent
of the increased wealth of this country
went to the top 1% and ninety-nine
percent of the increased wealth went to
the top 20% the CEOs of major
corporations now earn a hundred and
seventy times what their work is make
the largest gap between CEO and worker
of any major nation now we wrote this
book a few months ago but we're already
way out of date because the latest
statistics last year and you know last
year of CEOs received a fifty-four
percent increase in their compensation
way while working people received about
a three or four percent and many workers
or decline so when we talked about the
gap between CEO and work of being
hundred and seventy two one hey we were
ready a way out of date it's now over
two hundred to one in nineteen
eighty-two there were twelve
billionaire's in the United States today
there are 835 billionaire's and we have
people like mr. gates who has now worth
somewhere between 20 and 30 billion
dollars meanwhile the past twenty of
year twenty years have seen declining or
stagnant income for eighty percent of
all american families in fact adjusted
for inflation the average pay of
four-fifths of american workers
plummeted sixteen percent in 20 years
and we see that all over our state state
of vermont we see it all over mark what
does it mean it means that people are
working longer hours now you remember
in history way way back when 20 30 years
ago when actually one breadwinner in a
family could actually earn enough income
to take care of the family over that
ancient history some of a Greek
civilization when one person could bring
in enough income that does not exist in
Vermont and that exists in very few
places in the country women now whether
they want to or not many women do want
to work but many women would prefer to
stay home with the kids but that option
is not open to them anymore because
wages have not kept pace with inflation
the inflation-adjusted median income for
young families with children headed by
persons younger than 30 plunge
thirty-two percent between 1973 and 1990
20 years ago American workers were the
best compensated in the world we win
number one today american workers ranked
13th among industrialized nations in
terms of compensation and benefits in
other words all over europe europe has
its own economic problems high
unemployment but workers in germany who
are in manufacturing make twenty-five
percent more than american workers they
have far more time off much more better
much better benefits in 1973 the average
American worker earned four hundred and
forty five dollars a week twenty years
later that same worker was making 373
dollars a week and they are working
harder for less money us work is put in
about 200 more hours per year than West
European workers who typically obtained
for 25 week vacation often legally
mandated how many folks that we have
work in the state of month we get four
or five weeks paid vacations not too
many so with all of the new technology
and all of the automation and all of the
information highway and all of the
computers the end result is that for the
average person they're working longer
hours less time with the kids and we
talked a little bit about why that is so
and how we might be able to change it
now let me talk a little bit about the
other issue that gets as I mentioned
earlier very very little discussion that
is corporate control of the media a
knowledgeable and informed electorate is
essential is essential to a working
democracy we fall far short of that idea
ideal a
ssible source of the crisis in American
democracy is the Alec a legate a legate
alagappa Lee there it is alagappa Lee a
handful of mega corporations controlling
the media which essentially ascent
ostensibly informs Americans about what
is happening and what our political
choices are Americans get about
eighty-five percent of their news from
television almost all of that comes
through six major television networks
NBC is owned by GE CBS by Westinghouse
ABC by Disney and Fox by Rupert mirka
Rupert Murdoch CNN was recently bought
by Time Warner the world's largest
entertainment conglomerate public
television is also can greet
increasingly controlled by a wide
variety of corporate interests and the
point that we make is that you cannot
have a vital democracy unless people
have information about what is happening
in their country so you just stop and
think for a moment think about the
enormous amount of time that the media
decided to give us about oj simpson
everything you never wanted to know I
think they still do programs on oj
simpson okay meanwhile the collapse of
the middle class hey they missed that
story just couldn't quite get and I
remember you know talking and I you know
get around and I talked to some of these
guys who heads of television networks
and it's very clear it's clear for two
things number one the when you have
corporate control over the media
obviously they don't want to raise
issues which conflict with their own
well-being if we know to be the case the
general electric in the early years of
Ronald Reagan pay nothing in taxes and
they want to go back to the date when
this large multi-billion dollar
corporation pays nothing in taxes you
think they're going to talk about the
fact that the tax burden and
corporations has declined significantly
over the last 20 years they're not going
to talk about that and the burden has
been shifted onto the middle class
they're not going to talk about that and
if we are concerned about the absurd
trade policy of this country and the
fact the companies like GE are taking
our jobs to China with a hiring people
at twenty and thirty cents an hour
they're going to be talking about that
too much I don't thinks and if they're
not going to be also when GE and
companies like that or major
manufacturers of military equipment you
know we were on the floor of the house
just a few weeks ago I was leading the
effort to try to reduce military
spending can't quite figure out while we
have to spend 262 billion dollars this
year for the military that's only part
of it then you got the intelligence
budget and got nuclear power anything
about three hundred billion dollars a
year on the military and you go up the
Gingrich and it started by the way who
is the enemy can't be China because we
just voted for most favored nation
status with China I didn't vote for it
but Gingrich did clinton wants that
corporate america's investing tens of
billions of dollars in china it can't be
China it's not Russia corporate
America's investing huge amounts of
money in Russia is it really three
hundred billion dollars a year against
Cuba maybe that is a little bit of an
overkill maybe maybe and then you add
NATO's couple hundred billion dollars on
top of that it makes no sense at all but
you know those are issues that we don't
see for example I mean it's almost no
reporting of what's going on in terms of
the military budget it and we're very
proud Ben and Jerry's in the state
played a very good role trying to call
attention but national ads with other
progressive businesses why don't we cut
military spending when we have the
highest rate of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world twenty-two percent
of our kids why don't we cut military
spending on the CIA budget the
intelligent budget I helped lead the
effort to try to do that when you have
millions of American families can't
afford to send their kids to college why
don't we do that well we don't discuss
that too much so I make a long story
short you know what we try to do in the
book is talk a little bit about some of
the issues that I try to raise in
Congress that many Republicans and
Democrats don't want to raise that the
corporate media certainly does not want
allow to be discussing and in all
humility I think it's a good book it's a
readable book because what we do is I
mean it's not a complicated but it's not
this boring treatise on political theory
what we do is go back and forth between
the campaign we take you into the
campaign and then we switch it back to
maybe my early political days and go
back to the campaign and now finally
ends up on election night so I hope that
you will enjoy the book I think it has
some good information and I want to
thank all of you for the support that
many of you have given me over the years
and delighted to answer any questions if
people have them and thank you very much
fire away yes I think you're supposed to
talk into the mic I'm what they call an
atomic veteran we work for 25 years to
get benefits for atomic veterans so I
know that a few people can do something
but i'd like to ask why isn't anything
discussed about the fact that gulf war
was a nuclear war there's nothing said
about depleted uranium what's happening
to these young people well as you may or
may not know I know if you know it when
I am playing an active role in that
whole issue let me just say a word to
about that and I'm playing there's a
fellow from Connecticut crochets who's
headed the committee that online and
he's doing that an excellent job in
raising the issue now let me back up and
tell you what's been going on after the
Persian Gulf War some of the veterans
were coming home and they're saying
we're not feeling well we're having X
and we're having pains or having
gastrointestinal problems or sexual
problems we're having memory loss wives
are getting sick diarrhea we're having a
whole bunch of problems which has been
defined as Persian Gulf syndrome ah and
the initial response from the Department
of Defense and the VA was there is no
problem hey everybody gets sick you know
what's the problem and more and more
vets were coming back and say no no no I
went over there I was healthy I can
barely walk now I'm really debilitated
something is wrong and finally if
they're a lot of vets began to stand up
raise the issue the DoD in the VA they
said yes we acknowledge there is a
problem and we have concluded that the
problem is stress-related
okay now the fact of the matter is is
all of you know stresses in fact a
serious issue and we all know that
people sitting in the midst of a war
suffer from stress I you know it's not a
joke but clearly more in more of the
symptoms that we're developing and more
and more of the studies that independent
physicians were doing were suggesting
that this was far more than just the
stress prob so what have we learn we
learned that the DoD administered to
well over 200,000 of our soldiers
piratas stigma and bromide which they
used in an experimental basis they got a
waiver from the FDA and used for the
first time in a way like this as a net
anti nerve gas agent and then we also
found that the Persian Gulf theater the
military theater there was a chemical
cesspool that a lot of these guys were
using all kinds of pesticides and
insecticides we had burning oil wells
there was the use of depleted uranium is
the gentleman may indicate for the first
time in a war we used weapons that
pierced went right through Iraqi tanks
there was a young man in northern
Vermont whose job was to take Iraqi
bodies out of those destroyed tanks and
for the first time people were exposed
to that type of radiation um and then
what happened is more and more people
began to sign up for the registries
which were developed and we now have an
estimated 60 or 70,000 people who have
signed the registries with various
symptoms I've been working hard in this
issue we just released the other day
right here in our own state which only
sent over about 325 members of the
National Guard I'm not quite sure how
many active duty members we think maybe
100 hundred and fifty that we're finding
some hundred and fifty of our own people
have various symptoms including what
really concerns me is a number of these
young men are having memory problems
which suggests to me that there may be
some neurological problems that i met
with these guys last month very serious
problem some of the women are getting
sick as well so to answer your question
if we had left the now you also know
that at the end of World War two the
Department of Defense when they exploded
atomic
arms in the southwest despite the fact
that there were physicians and
scientists who then knew the potential
danger of radiation our troops were
exposed to that a lot of American troops
surrounded those bomb blasts and it took
years and years before we finally got
the DoD to recognize that problem you
are aware that in Vietnam a lot of our
soldiers were exposed to Agent Orange it
took the veterans organizations and
enormous amount of work working with
people in Congress to finally get the
truth out about what agent orange was
about so we think we're into that fight
again and we are working very very hard
I just submitted to members of Congress
a couple of weeks ago a letter which
said please tell the presidential
Advisory Committee on persian gulf
illness who had concluded that stress is
the cause of the problems that they've
got to look at the impact of chemicals
and without much trouble i had 85 other
members of congress sign that letter and
we're working very hard on that issue
and in fact in the next couple of weeks
i hope to get an appropriation to get
money out of the DoD in the VA to an
independent government agency to look of
what we call the synergistic impact of
chemicals I happen to believe that were
you looking at as a form of multiple
chemical sensitivity these guys have
embarked they took drugs they've been
boarded by chemicals and I think that's
at least one of the reasons why they're
ill so we're working really hard on that
issue the DoD and the VA it just it's
like pulling teeth it is not easy other
questions or thoughts gentleman right
here
in today's New York Times was a
full-page ad by the Concord Coalition
and they're making the point I've been
making this for a long time that since
Americans live longer than they used to
longevity has been increasing that
therefore they should be working longer
and not be Medicare eligible at 65 or
social security eligible at 65 now I'm a
c-span junkie and I depend on your vote
to know which way it's going but I have
never heard it a congressional hearing
deal with this topic nor ever seen floor
debates on this and it's important for
my sons and the sons and daughters of
many others here thank you very much for
that very important portion we held a
press conference on that in Burlington
last week and came out very very
strongly against raising the age of the
67 in addition to that they want to
charge five dollars for home visits and
make it harder for people to get the
oxygen that they need to get at home let
me talk about that um you have heard on
CBS and NBC and ABC a lot about deficit
you haven't heard too much about our
trade crisis the decline of the standard
of living of American workers the
growing gap between the rich and the
poor the fact that we have the highest
rate of childhood poverty but you have
heard about the deficit situation is the
deficit situation an important issue it
is in my view should we move the country
to the balanced budget we should let's
talk about a couple things first point
that I want to make is how many of you
know that in the last four years
Congress has made significant progress
in moving this country toward a balanced
budget in 1993 as I recall the budget
deficit was close to 300 billion dollars
a year that's a lot of money it is now
down to about 45 billion dollars and one
of the reasons that we've had some
success is that after Clinton took
office and one of the good thing in this
book right
but one of the good things that he did
do after he took office in his first
budget was to raise taxes on the rich
and the large corporations and in fact
lower taxes on the working poor I think
he now sees that almost as a mistake he
offended his wealthy friends but
nonetheless it won by I think one vote
in the house and I was the only non
Democrat that voted for it and one in
the Senate I think also by one vote or
something but the deficit is it is an
important problem and we have made
progress now when we talk about deficit
reduction there are various ways that
you can balance a budget let me give you
some ways you can cut the hell out of
Medicare Gingrich wanted to cut Medicare
by 270 billion dollars over a six-year
period several years ago and we stop
that but this time mr. Clinton and
Republicans have come together and
decided to cut Medicare by a hundred and
fifteen billion dollars over a five-year
period not in a way that hurts
financially the individual button
cutting back substantial amounts of
money to provide us in our own state of
Vermont our small state the hospitals
would lose 75 million dollars elderly
people over five year period which means
that the cost is going to be passed on
to the private insurance companies or do
you for out-of-pocket costs are charged
can you imagine this somebody with an
acute illness a senior citizen at home
will now have to pay five dollars for
every home care home health visit which
if you needed somebody to come to your
house three times a week could run you
you know six seven hundred dollars a
year they put a cap on it but I think
it's about seven hundred dollars now if
you're trying to get by on a to nine
thousand dollars a year to paying an
addition well you know seven hundred
dollars is outrageous and of course the
premiums was scheduled to go up so you
can cut back on Medicare you can cut
back on Medicaid you can is Gingrich one
or two do not cling to his credit cut
back on higher education you can cut
back on environmental protection you can
throw children off of welfare seventy
percent of the people on welfare our
children and if you do all of those
things you know what you can move toward
a balanced budget you can do it I happen
to think that that's in immoral and
outrageous way to move toward a balanced
budget so let me give you an alternative
way that you can move to
a budget which mr. Gingrich certainly
does not agree with and President
Clinton does not agree with okay let's
talk about welfare and let's understand
that a lot more welfare is given to
large multinational corporations than is
given to poor people both right-wing and
left-wing and sensuous groups agree that
we spend about a hundred and twenty five
billion dollars that's with a be a year
on corporate welfare we have wonderful
programs that encourage and help
corporate America invest in third world
countries so that we can throw American
workers out on the street we have
programs which encourage large
multinational corporations in the
defense industry to merge and in the
process layoff American workers give us
less competition so the taxpayers will
end up paying more money and on we have
huge tax breaks you know the business
people who can take out their friends
the fancy restaurants for a couple of
hundred bucks for a meal and we allow
them deductions for that accelerated
appreciation depreciation and on and on
it goes okay so if you're serious about
deficit reduction and you have the guts
to stand up the big money then you take
a hard look at corporate welfare second
of all the defense budget and the
intelligence budget we're just going
through that right now as I indicated
earlier both Democrats and Republicans
agree and the president that roughly
speaking we should have a budget
military budget about two hundred and
sixty two billion dollars a year the
Republicans one on the floor of the
house more money for b-2 bombers that
the Pentagon deneva want you know what
one b-2 bomber costs costs a billion and
a half of dollars for one plane okay
putting that into perspectives anyone
know what the budget of the entire state
of Vermont is for 600,000 people it's
about a billion and a half dollars one
bloody plane equals the budget of our
entire state they've heard a lot of
discussion recently about the National
Endowment for the Arts alright Gingrich
in his friends want to kill it we just
can't afford it in this country to get
arts into the schools provide low-income
people access to the odds help artists
you know create can't afford to do it
one hundred million dollars the entire
National Endowment for the Arts less
than ten percent of one
bloody beat obama that the Pentagon
doesn't want any increased funding for
the v2 bombs we spend about a hundred we
spend about a hundred billion dollars a
year defending Europe and Asia against
home well as soon as I get that answer I
will come right back here to Manchester
Vermont and I'll tell you hundred
billion dollars a year okay from 1972
1997 major pieces of tax legislation was
passed by the United States Congress on
the Democratic presidents Republican
presidents and mostly Democratic
Congress's the results of those seven
pieces of tax legislation is that for
ninety percent of the people in America
that is the middle class the working
class lower income people taxes went up
for the offi ten percent and the largest
corporations taxes went down now given
the fact that corporations they are
contributing significantly smaller
percentages of money to our treasury
given the fact that we've seen a
proliferation of millionaires and
billionaires I know it's a terribly
radical idea I know it but that's why
you sent me to Congress right to say
that may be millionaires and
billionaires might be asked to pay more
in taxes so we can bring in more revenue
and lower taxes for the middle class and
working people now what happened during
that period under during the 70s and the
80s why did them who knows why but
curiously if you know what was the major
area that the middle class saw an
increase in their taxes who knows you
know you say it every day what is it
Social Security and Medicare the FICA
taxes they went way up so the right now
you're paying about seven and a half
percent of your paycheck in FICA taxes
Social Security and Medicare before you
pay your first nickel in income taxes
you think and it's a totally regressive
tax because there is a maximum they've
decided our friend Alan Greenspan to
work with the with the Reagan on this
issue decided whistle Maxima 67,000 yeah
something like that
cited that somebody who make 67 thousand
dollars a year will pay the same in FICA
taxes as somebody who makes a million
dollars again meanwhile they lower tie
income taxes for the rich and large
corporations raise the FICA tax so in
our state which has a very high
percentage of self-employed people you
know what they're paying in FICA seven
and a half plus seven and a half before
they pay their first nickel in income
tax totally regressive totally
regressive tax but that's so there are
three or four ways that you can move to
balance the budget in a way that is fair
you go after corporate welfare you go
after the intelligence budget yo after
the military budget and you create a tax
system that has some strength and more
progressivity than what we have if you
do that not only can you balance the
budget but you will have substantially
money substantial money's left over to
start dealing with our national debt and
to adequately fund education so that
families all over this country will be
able to be able to send their kids to
college maybe we can make a dent in the
twenty two percent of our kids who live
in poverty deal with the environment in
a strong way now the question book
dresses well why doesn't that happen I
would say most people in America believe
that that's the case should happen it
doesn't happen because we have a system
and majority of people don't vote don't
know what's going on and members of
Congress are surrounded by these
corporate lobbyists who know exactly
what committee and what member to go to
and that's why the rich get richer and
almost everybody else gets poorer should
we balance the budget yeah but we can do
it in a fair and progressive way and not
hurt the elderly the pool or working
families gentlemen right here
you uh you mentioned this vote on the
foundation for the Arts has a very
distressing boat and from the inside
where I'm sure you see it what is a
composition of this right that we're
dealing with who are these people I mean
this was a very troubling vote yes and
amex boat I think what happened Gingrich
is revolution and and we have to you
know somebody who opposes virtually
everything the game word stands for we
have to give him credit for being a
brilliant political organ organ Iser and
a brilliant idea log essentially you
have in Congress right now you know just
to generalize in a simple sense you have
older Republicans who are conservatives
they're conservatives they want to see
everything being equal they want to
protect their wealthy friends they want
to see the government play a less active
role and so forth and so on but what
Gingrich did is encourage a much harsher
and more right-wing a group of people
and he led them and he raises enormous
sums of money from his wealthy friends
and then they have a very tight network
by which they literally have almost like
a farm team by which they get very
bright young people in the legislators
they get them to run for Congress they
adequately fund them and they given them
the right buzz words now the National
Endowment for the Arts is when i talked
about scapegoating and playing off one
group of Americans whether you you know
blacks are played off against whites or
immigrants against native born or women
against men but the National Endowment
for the Arts this is the way it goes
here's the speech diesel 30-second
speech do you want your tax dollars to
go to fund ugly pornography which does
this that and the other thing is that
way you want your tax dollars to go and
then what they will do is they'll check
out that sometimes sometimes they lie
sometimes it's true that you had some
program some mount the money going to
some artists who did something ugly with
it neglecting to mention that and maybe
that is you know a fraction of one
percent of all of the audience by now so
this is what you'll hear about over and
over again what they will not talk about
is that here in the state of Vermont and
in schools throughout this country
kids are being exposed the wonderful
cultural programs that they would not be
exposed to if there wasn't for the NEA
our own Vermont counts on the author's
traditionally done a great job as have
similar groups throughout the country so
what they do is part of their thing is
you can take out I mean welfare is the
same thing in any area of life there's
always going to be abuse right in any of
your life so what you do is you take out
one area of abuse you play it over and
over again and that's your 30-second
sound bite do you want your taxpayer
dollars to go to this ugly example of
pornography and you got the right wing
who is they worked very hard on that
issue I don't think to tell you the
truth I mean again what the American
people probably don't understand that
the entire National Endowment for the
Arts which allows millions of people to
enjoy theater music art is less than ten
percent of one b-2 bomber so it is what
most people also do not understand they
compared to European countries we spend
a fraction of public money on the arts
compared to what what you're up to us
and it becomes in a very way a very you
know to my minor and we when I was mayor
Burlington we work very hard we
slaughtered our own mayor's Council on
the arts which is something you get up
to Burlington you know we have a dozen
things going on and what the importance
of that is is that art and culture is
part of what human life is about and I i
believe and i think many members of
Congress believe that it's wrong is that
that whole area of human existence be
open only to people who can pay 50 bucks
to buy a seat to go to a concert you
know and you need public funding for the
Arts to make arts affordable or to make
it free and I think I would to be very
honest with you raise substantially the
amount of money that we put into the
odds but to say the least it is an
outrage that they want to cut it
gentleman in the back yes please yeah
sir
I wanted to uh also add to the question
that the gentleman just asked but more
environmental terms about the people who
are up against in Congress now already
we've seen an awful lot of damage done
to the environment and a lot of twos and
twos not adding up to four for instance
in terms of flood damage there's an
incredible amount of flood damage
happening whenever there's too much
water because the watersheds of
integrated there's no more soil to uh
take up the water now what is it that
these people in Congress actually see in
terms of future generations where's
their urgency and and do they simply
expect the world to be paved over etc
etc well one of the things that I I
first you know one of the first strong
feelings that I had when I was went to
Congress in 1991 I come home to Vermont
almost every weekend and I try to get
around the state and I try to talk to as
many people as I can you know when you
go out you talk to ordinary people in
Vermont they're hurting you know many of
people don't have health care they're
paying too much for healthcare elderly
people can't afford their prescription
drugs people working longer hours so
there's a sense of urgency that I take
with me back to Washington but you go
back to Washington and you got a number
of people who live in a different world
they live in a country club world where
you know you have fifty dollar dinners
or hundred dollar you know activities
and so forth and so on they city
fundraising dinners for the republican
party with the democratic party where
people come up and raised there was one
just to massachusetts i think yes there
was in the boston globe all it cost you
to go to a very nice fundraising dinner
at somebody's house was twenty thousand
dollars a couple not bad most people I
don't I know do not spend twenty
thousand dollars for dinner in an
evening and whenever I say that people
laugh and they can't believe it twenty
thousand dollars I mean Gingrich and
bought the president have held
fundraising the fifty thousand dollars a
couple now what world is that in what
relationship does that have to do to the
overwhelming majority of working
families in the state run it is another
world entirely so when you get caught up
in that world then you hear the problems
of the people who spend fifty thousand
dollars for dinner and I suppose they
have problems but they're not the
problems the most of that my
constituents have and I live in a
somewhat different world so what ends up
happening
and this is the culture in the climate
and let me also say here I don't mean to
say it's very easy to be anti-congress I
want to tell you something that there
are dozens and dozens and dozens of very
good members of Congress many of whose
names you don't know and I think many of
them are in the Progressive Caucus and
they work 60 70 80 hours a week for
their constituents and they're doing
exactly the right thing you know doing
the best that they can but you got a
hell of a lot of people there who
associate with millionaires and
billionaires who receive a lot of
corporate packs and they look at the
world from that point of view so then
what they say is gee whiz if we you know
if the question if the issue becomes
controlling corporate profits as opposed
to protecting the environment there's
not much of a choice if you have
received hundreds of thousands of
dollars from corporate polluters and
that's basically what goes on yes what
are your thoughts on the workfare
component of the new welfare system put
forth by the president I had I think
clearly that if somebody can work they
should be asked to work but I think what
we should understand that when we're
talking about so-called welfare reform
is that seventy percent of the people
who are affected our children that you
have many low-income women who wanted to
raise their kids as best they could with
limited resources that the so-called
welfare reform bill and I say so called
because I don't think it's real welfare
reform but that that legislation often
will force women out of their homes
without providing a adequate childcare
for because I don't know what happens to
a woman with two young kids who is now
forced to work where there is not
adequate or affordable a child care
second of all there are a lot of people
don't have the skills that are necessary
now there's a big debate I don't know
how much you've read about it but that
our Republican friends now think that
people you know we gotta get these
people to work work is wonderful work is
what it's about well now what they want
to do is take people who are in work for
you know what not allow them to earn the
minimum wage that I them the minimum
wage now that is not only unfair to
those people you know what else it does
it low is the entire wage structure for
everybody so that if you have a
cafeteria worker in a local school who's
making six bucks an hour here in
Manchester and the town can hire
somebody for four bucks an hour below
the minimum wage that six dollar an hour
person may lose her job or else wages
will be bidded down even lower which is
a strong strategy of what the Republican
Party now stands for last year when we
fought to raise the minimum wage and was
successful we had to beat back an
amendment very powerful amendment I got
a lot of Republican Party support that
would have eliminated the concept of the
minimum wage for small businesses so you
had people in Vermont that all over this
country forced to work for three or four
bucks an hour and not only is that
unfair and wrong for those people once
again it low is the wage structure and
forces wages down which is ultimately
what NAFTA is about and what most
favored nation status with China is
about essentially right now American
workers are being forced to compete
against people in Mexico earn seventy
cents an hour people in in China were
earning twenty or thirty cents an hour
you follow what's going on with Nike you
see what Nike does nike goes to any
place in the world where they pay the
lowest possible wages they're now in
Vietnam they've discovered Vietnam
that's now the lowest wage area in the
world see hiring women there for twenty
cents an hour and then they bring the
product back to the United States they
sell it to our kids for a hundred bucks
hundred and fifty bucks and the guy who
owns nike Philip night ends up with five
billion dollars in personal profit and
we're trying to work on that issue as a
matter of fact we're saying to miss the
night that if the people in this country
are good enough to buy Nike sneakers
maybe we might be good enough to
manufacture some of them as well so
other questions or gentleman right here
would you say to somebody who would
support changes in welfare laws that
they're supporting the rich because they
think the old system wasn't working Sean
and the old system was like the question
is in case the mic didn't pick it up
what about people who think we should
change the welfare system not because
they want to protect the wealthy because
they think it wasn't working i would say
you're right it wasn't working it wasn't
working so we want to make it work and
how do we make it work well number one
if we are asking people to work I think
that that's totally appropriate okay but
then we want to make sure a that there's
a job available don't we write we can
say to you we demand that you work but
gee there is no job available that your
skills will allow you to take that's
unfair and the second thing we've got to
say is that we think that no parent in
America should be for us to do the wrong
thing by his or her kids now if you had
your single dad saying you had two kids
we say we want you to work okay you have
a right to say yeah but I want to see my
kids get adequate childcare I think we
have that right so I think that is at
the heart of what was wrong with
so-called welfare reform so I believe in
welfare reform real welfare reform but
what was passed in the last Congress was
not real welfare reform throwing
hundreds of thousands of disabled
children off of their benefits is not
real welfare reform telling an immigrant
who came to this country legally not
illegally who came to this country
legally who was working who is playing
taxes that he and his family are not
eligible for American benefits when they
always had been there paying taxes
that's not right either so I do believe
in real welfare reform the system has
not worked well no question about it we
wanted to change the system
unfortunately I don't think the changes
that were brought about with proper
changes illegal immigrants serious
problem it is a very serious problem and
I think we've got to deal with that if
somebody does something illegally it's
illegal and we got to stop it we gotta
figure out how to stop it one of the
interesting points that I would make
about illegal immigration is that it is
no secret and this is not much of an
issue here in the state of Vermont it is
an issue in California and in states
that border mexico is that as you know
many employers loved illegal immigrants
didn't they because they can hire people
who did not have their papers for below
minimum wage you can exploit the hell
out of those people because we're they
going to go they're going to go to the
police I don't think so so you know some
of the major
perpetrators of the problem of illegal
immigration or employers who really
wanted to get the slave labor almost
other thoughts of questions woman in the
back if you want to come up to the mic
please in person most of a child care i
do childcare and i've done she'll carry
out of advocacy for years and there is
not anything like the number of child
care slots that we need for work fair
but I can go out of my field you
mentioned agent orange which made me
think of our good friends at Monsanto is
all good friends again the government I
know it's an issue in Vermont because of
BST Congress the government the FDA
anyone going to touch genetically
engineered crops before they're out
there well let me let me I think
probably not but let me back up with I
introduced I think the only resolution
that was introduced about BST which all
of you know is a synthetic product made
by Monsanto which is a multi-billion
dollar chemical and agribusiness
corporation and it seemed to me that for
two reasons we were concerned about it
in the state of Vermont number one
family farmers all over America
including the state of Vermont are
suffering from low milk prices and we're
losing our family phones we fought very
hard for the Northeast dairy compact
which will help somewhat but the last
thing in the world that we need is more
milk being produced to drive prices down
even though and the second concern which
was a health concern is given the fact
that we have already an abundance of
natural milk I don't know why we wanted
to get milk from cows that studies that
indicated were made sick up by being
stressed out what you were doing is
forcing the cow to produce significantly
more milk now is that something we want
human mothers to do we want to give them
a product to force them to produce one
milk I don't think so and I don't think
we want our kids necessarily drinking
that milk from account so we fought very
hard but when you take on companies like
Monsanto I had the guy who was head of
the FDA in my office now Congress does
not deal with one sentence one tantos
decide what they want to do in Congress
follows women something once they're
just too big and powerful for Congress
that's the real I mean like many other
multinational corporations and what you
should understand and you don't
understand the American people don't
understand it they always get what they
want now sometimes it may take them an
extra couple of months to get it they
may be slow down but they don't stop
when they defeated they come back and
they come back and they come back and
they have an army of lobbyists and
public relations people and they fought
for the staff to think every corporation
in America told us how great naphtha was
well four years later NAFTA has been a
disaster lowered wages we lost hundreds
of thousands of jobs they're still not
one major newspaper in America
editorially will even tell us that
they're slow program so it is a it is it
is a tough issue taking on corporate
America that is the struggle of our
times this book attempts to talk a
little bit about it and I guess is my my
time rapidly elapsing here so it's yeah
all right let me just just say is you
know I am so proud to represent our
great state and I appreciate the
willingness of the people of Vermont to
put up with somebody who is not a
Democrat not a Republican who sometimes
has ideas a little bit outside of the
mainstream and I thank you all very much
for your support over the years
thank you all for coming Bernie Sanders
will be sitting here at the table you
can have further discussion with him and
you'll be happy to sign a book for you